-Our first guest tonight
is an Academy and Tony
Award-nominated actor
you know from films such
as "Boyhood" and "Training Day."
He is the co-creator,
executive producer, and star
of Showtime's limited series
"The Good Lord Bird,"
which airs Sundays at 10:00 P.M.
Let's take a look.
-What is it that you want
in this direct moment?
-The freedom of every Negr
in this building.
Safe passage for all of my men
across the B&O Bridge,
and then I will surrender myself
directly to you.
-Mr. Brown, you are in
no position to negotiate.
-Give me a hundred yards'
head start.
-Please welcome back to
the show and the studio,
Ethan Hawke, everybody!
♪♪♪♪
-[ Hums along ]
-I can't believe it!
-Look at all the people.
-Right along this way, sir
-Look -- Wow!
-Look at it.
-It's amazing!
No, no, no, it's too much!
It's too much.
Stop applauding.
-We got like nine for you.
-Yeah.
-How are you?
Nine's a big number.
-Is this the safe distance
-This is a safe distance.
-This is our imaginary friend.
-Hey, I want to talk
about the show.
One thing I want to say before
we get too far away
from the clip,
I was watching
the season finale,
which is fantastic,
the series finale.
The makeup is so good.
You are so convincingly dirt
in this whole last episode
Sometimes that is a very har
thing to achieve,
and your makeup people
did a fantastic job.
-Well, his name is
David Atherton,
and he's a makeup artist
I've worked with before.
A lot of -- you know, director
are like quarterbacks.
I mean, actors are like
quarterbacks.
We get so much credit for things
that are not our doing.
-Yes.
-And this guy happens
to study --
He did a college thesis
on character development.
And we had so much fun getting
to work in a canvas this big
a seven-hour movie,
and to play an iconic figure
like John Brown.
What does he look like?
Why does he grow his beard
How does the beard look?
What does the beard tell you
What does it communicate?
You know?
And he was in a gunfight
for a slew of days
and he needed to be dirty.
-Yeah.
And it's just a really --
think sometimes you can tell
when somebody like just
throws the dirt on.
-No, this guy didn't do that
He really obsesses over it
And I obsess over it too,
so we had a lot of fun.
I'm so glad you brought that u
because I never get to give hi
the props that he deserves
I texted him just today.
It's our performance.
-Yeah.
-It's not just mine.
-It is. And it's a terrifi
performance.
before we talk about that,
you know, this is --
I feel like these last
nine months,
people look for
silver linings.
One of my silver linings i
you and I figured out,
we knew each other from
shows like this,
that we were
pandemic neighbors,
and I got to know you
and your family...
-It's amazing.
-And it was one of
the silver linings.
-I even snuck into your closet
-You snuck into my closet.
We actually have a clip.
You were the only guest
who appeared in the attic show
and not really appear.
But let's take a look
at Ethan's work here.
It's not like there's magic door
behind me that will
send me a guest if I say
their name three times.
Ethan Hawke, Ethan Hawke,
Ethan Hawke. Right?
I mean, that would be stupid
But also, I mean, how cool
would that be?
[ Laughter ]
Do you remember the thing that
was notable about that day
-That we got in trouble?
-We got in trouble.
We immediately --
the network was like,
"You gotta let us know if
Ethan Hawke's gonna be there."
-Yeah.
-But it was also like
a thousand degrees
in the attic.
-It was so hot!
And you had to keep
redoing the take
and I had to be trapped
in that closet, like,
"Seth, get your lines
right, dude.
I cannot stay here any longer.
-I got a little nervous when
you're -- you know.
-When I was trapped in the
darkness, you got nervous?
-I didn't get nervous
about you.
I got nervous about --
I feel like when I have to act
with someone of your caliber..
-Oh, really?
-...I get a little, you know
so I think I was --
-I feel that way on the show
You know, this is not my world
and I think all of us,
when we are out of our element
you have to -- you know,
it knocks you off balance.
-Are you less nervous or mor
nervous with no audience?
-You know, I'm asking myself
why am I feeling so nervou
right this second?
And I think it's because
there's nobody here.
-Yeah, there's no cushion
to anything.
-Yeah, you don't get a laugh
It's very --
It makes me feel like
something's wrong
or like we're rehearsing,
you know?
-Oh, yeah, we are gonna do thi
for an audience in a month
-We'll do it for real later.
Okay, cool. All right.
Then I think this is
going great.
-This was -- we talked a lot
this summer about
how you'd put so much
work into this.
You and your wife Ryan wer
producers of this as well.
And this is a book by
James McBride.
And, obviously, one of the
things you have to do
when you adapt a work
of this magnitude
is get the trust of the author
-Of the author, yeah.
How did that go down, and wa
he happy with the outcome?
-Well, he would have to spea
to that himself.
I can tell you that if I had
to pinpoint the greatest
professional moment of my life
it was when James saw the season
finale and called me.
You know,
we had been working on it.
He is an executive produce
on it too.
I met him at a cafe in Brooklyn.
He is a man of immense
personal integrity.
He's hysterically funny,
and he's kind,
and he's the kind of artis
you walk away from
and you think,
"Oh, that's what an artist
is supposed to be like."
I mean, he just has real grace
And my wife and I left
that meeting going,
I want to do anything
that puts me more in contact
with people like that, right
But he trusted us with thi
material.
And that was a heavy
responsibility.
So to get -- you know, we sent
him the final cut of the thing
and he called me up, and he just
-- he couldn't believe it.
We were going to make
John Brown famous!
You know,
and he was so happy.
And when he was happy, you know,
when I kind of
honored that handshake
to somebody
I admire as much as him,
it meant a lot to me.
-We're gonna be right back
to talk to you more.
Because one of the things I want
to talk about
is how little we all know
about John Brown
and how James McBride's
approach to that...
-Okay.
-...sent this series
in the direction it went.
We'll be right back with more.
-Can people pretend to applaud
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah!
-We'll be right back
with more Ethan Hawke.
-Great job, Seth!